bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour l'entretien de france 24 le monde a
les yeux rivés vers l'ukraine car
vladimir poutine et soupçonnés de
préparer une invasion et pour tenter de
rentrer dans un jeu un peu exclusif
entre la russie et les etats unis le
président emmanuel macron a remis en
marche un format a4 dit format de
normandie c'est un peu à notre invité
qu'il le doit pierre vimont bonjour je
rappelle que vous êtes ambassadeur
diplomate négociateur précédemment
directeur de cabinet de dominique de
villepin aux affaires étrangères ancien
ambassadeur aux états unis mais aussi à
bruxelles au secrétaire général exécutif
du service européen pour l'action
extérieure
et puis aujourd'hui représentant du
président de la république pour l'
architecture de sécurité et de confiance
avec la russie ça consiste en quoi
exactement
il faut merci d'abord de m'avoir invité
ça consiste en fait à mettre en oeuvre
l'initiative qu'avait prises le
président de la république à l'été 2010
neuf donc il ya il ya plus de deux ans
on oublie parfois
initiative qui consistait à relancer un
dialogue avec la russie d'abord sur le
plan bilatéral et puis aussi si c'était
possible sur le plan au plan européen et
donc tout au long de ces deux dernières
années on a développé une discussion de
travail avec nos interlocuteurs russes
on a développé donc un canal de
communication et d'information qui s'est
révélé utile pendant cette période de
crise
parce que il a permis de maintenir le
dialogue de la diplomatie ouverte et
donc c'est dans ce cadre là que le
président de la république a pu se
rendre à moscou la semaine dernière et
avoir cette discussion
franche
difficile parfois avec avec le président
poutine mais qui est utile dans cette
période de crise alors en ce moment
c'est en fait le président le pardon le
chancelier allemand olaf scholz ce qui
est arrivé en ukraine et puis se rend
ensuite à moscou pour y rencontrer le
président russe vladimir poutine est-ce
que lui aussi peut apaiser les choses et
ce que d'ailleurs il pourrait utiliser
une autre arme que les français comme le
fameux north stream de ce gazoduc qui
qui se pa plein qui contourne l'ukraine
pour livrer en particulier aux allemands
je crois que la visite du chancelier
allemand est utile comme celle du
président de l'as de la république la
semaine dernière d'abord parce que comme
je le disais tout à l'heure il faut tout
faire pour garder la porte ouverte et
donner sa chance à la diplomatie
même quand on entend les les bruits de
bottes que l'on nous parle de possible
intervention militaire
il faut toujours continuer à essayer de
faire avancer la la voie de la
diplomatie la voie du dialogue ça c'est
important mais le deuxième élément je
crois qu'il est important c'est que le
chancelier allemand comme le président
de la république font entendre la voix
de l'europe dans
cette crise on a beaucoup dit que
l'europe était marginalisé qu'on a
laissé de côté que ces intérêts étaient
et est ignorée et je pense donc qu'il
est important que des dirigeants de
l'union européenne soit en mesure de
faire entendre la voix de l'europe
c'est-à-dire de faire connaître ce que
sont nos intérêts dans cette affaire ce
que nous avons à défendre et de pouvoir
en particulier sur cette base essayer de
développer un dialogue avec avec le
président poutine et la russie bien sûr
tout ça doit se faire en concertation
avec nos partenaires américains avec le
même souci de fermeté et d'unité qui
doit être à la base de toute notre
politique mais le fait que le chancelier
allemand après le président français
puisse se rendre à moscou et avoir ce
dialogue c'est important bien évidemment
les allemands viennent avec avec leurs
propres armes avec leurs propres
arguments
vous avez parlé de la question du gaz
c'est en effet une question importante
avec la mise en place progressive
du gazoduc north stream 2 mais les
allemands d'autres arguments ils ont
aussi une position géopolitique
géostratégique qui est essentiel au
coeur de l'europe qui est centrale et
vous savez que le prédécesseur du
chancelier allemand madame angela merkel
avait développé aussi une relation
personnelle particulière
intensive je dirais avec avec la russie
est donc le rôle de l'allemagne est
important c'est ce qu'essaye de refaire
vous le dites de renouer olaf schulze
alors c'est vrai que la russie elle
demande en particulier à ce que une
adhésion de l'ukraine à l'otan et bien
soit validée par l d'un certain point de
vue ou en tout cas elle voudrait avoir
un droit de regard sur cette autant est
ce que c'est une demande qui d'un
certain point de vue est acceptable
est-ce qu'on n'est pas surtout en train
d' actes et que tout ce flanc ouest et
bien ne peut pas tomber dans la besace
de l'otan parce que sa fâcherie vladimir
poutine
non ce qui est ce qui a été rappelé
d'ailleurs très clairement par le
président de la république quand il
était à moscou c'est que nous avons tous
souscrit la russie y compris nous avons
tous souscrit un certain nombre de
principes intangibles il y à déjà
longtemps c'était déjà dans les accords
d'helsinki de 1975
renouvelé depuis lors dans la charte de
paris de 1990 est rappelé à l'occasion
de tous les les grands accords que nous
avons signés avec la russie lors de la
fin de la guerre froide
l'accord entre l'otan et la russie en
1997 d'autres déclarations que nous
avons pu faire y compris celles d'astana
en 2010 2011 donc ces accords ils ont
acté un certain nombre de principes
celui de l'indépendance de toutes les
nations européennes
le respect de leur souveraineté
nationale
respect de leur intégrité territoriale
et le droit pour tous ces pays de
décider tout seul independent toute
indépendance de leur avenir s'ils
veulent devenir membre ou non de le
temps membre ou non de l'union
européenne et il n'est pas question de
revenir sur ces accords à partir de là
on voit bien les craintes les
inquiétudes que peuvent développer les
russes par rapport à de telles à de
telles décisions et c'est sur ce point
les justement cesse de ma pièce immense
et malentendus est ce que ce serait
précisément le fait que la france et
vous en l'occurrence vous venez de
parler de préoccupations légitimes de la
russie il ya aussi les liens
énergétiques qu'on a mentionné étroits
entre l'allemagne et la russie font que
d'autres pays européens comme la pologne
les états membres sont maintenant vive
méfiant vis-à-vis de cette diplomatie
des deux grandes puissances et eux de
leur côté ils arment les ukrainiens
alors est ce que vous entendez ça aussi
sans lanta tout à fait parce qu'on
l'entend depuis longtemps au sein de
l'union européenne lorsque nous
discutons la russie tout au long de
l'année dernière à l'occasion de
plusieurs réunions du conseil européen
nous avons eu des discussions très
sérieuses très approfondies avec nos
partenaires européens qui ont fait
souvent l'objet d'ailleurs de désaccord
entre nous mais l'important c'est de
pouvoir en discuter et d'essayer
d'avancer alors qu'est ce qu'on voit
face à cette période de crise et bien on
a vu par exemple le président de la
pologne sud ou da venir à berlin et
discutée à la fois avec le président de
la république avec le chancelier
allemand sur une ligne commune qui est
celle comme je le disais tout à l'heure
de l'unité de la fermeté mais en même
temps celle du dialogue diplomatique et
de la recherche d'un processus
diplomatique qui nous permettrait de
sortir de la crise actuelle est d'aller
vers une baisse de l'ascension de la
tension elle est dommage escalade comme
souvent dit à paris a par là le
président joe biden a appelé ses
concitoyens à quitter l'ukraine les
occidentaux s'en vont les uns après les
autres et les ukrainiens se sentent
abandonnés
est ce qu'on n'en voit pas signons
finalement que la guerre et il avait
raison
écoutez on envoie des signaux qui sont
pour le moment contradictoires notamment
du côté américain et donc je pense qu'il
faut faire très attention en effet de ne
pas aboutir à déstabiliser nous-mêmes
l'ukraine le président de la république
a souligné combien les ukrainiens et le
président zielinski faisait preuve de
sang froid
actuellement dans les circonstances
actuelles et il faut absolument les
aider à maintenir cette position or nous
pouvons pas d'un côté leur apporter un
soutien notamment financier comme la
france l'a fait comme la commission
européenne vient de le faire également
avec un important paquet macro
financiers et de l'autre côté annoncé le
départ des ressortissants européens
la réduction considérable
des diplomates en poste à kiev ou même
comme on vient de le voir ces derniers
jours le retrait d'un certain nombre
d'observateurs de la mission
d'observation de l'osce et eux sur la
ligne de contact entre l'ukraine et la
zone des séparatistes donc oui il faut
faire très attention à ne pas
déstabiliser les graines et a au
contraire rester à leurs côtés et leur
montrer que l'europe et leurs
partenaires occidentaux restent à leurs
côtés et les soutiennent dans leur
attitude actuelle tout était question
pierre vimont sur sur la russie mais
cette fois ci au mali avec et ses
mercenaires de la force wagner qui
utilisent la faiblesse de certains états
pour s'implanter remplacer les européens
dans le sahel c'est une entreprise russe
qui finalement essaye de pérenniser
cette jeune agent qui confisque le
pouvoir au mali sous couvert de lutte
contre les djihadistes les français qui
sont en train de ce probablement de se
retirer ce qui ne laisse pas un terrain
de jeu terrible aux russes
écoutez sur la présence des forces
wagner des mercenaires wagner en afrique
dès le début de la relance du dialogue
avec la russie dont je parlais tout
celle qui a pris qu'à pris naissance en
2019 nous avions déjà abordé ce point là
avec avec la russie avec nos partenaires
et nos interlocuteurs russes à l'époque
c'était surtout autour de la république
centrafricaine que nous pouvions avoir
des inquiétudes et nous avions
clairement exprimé à nos interlocuteurs
russes que c'était pour nous un élément
extrêmement important dans le dialogue
avec la russie depuis lors rien n'a
changé en soirée publique centrafricaine
et les choses se sont aggravées
également au
mali avec maintenant une présence
également des wagner au mali donc oui
pour nous c'est un sujet extrêmement
important et nous le répétons à chaque
fois que nous discutons avec les russes
mais il faut replacer ce problème là
dans tout ce contexte est bien
évidemment le problème de la présence
française en afrique francophone et à
l'ouest de l'afrique c'est un problème
beaucoup plus large que celui des vagues
n'aient c'est un problème concernant nos
relations avec les autorités locales sur
place et sur toute la question de la
présence française et du soutien
militaire français accordé aux
différents pays de la région donc c'est
pas simplement le mali c'est aussi
le tchad c'est aussi le niger c'est
aussi le burkina faso et donc ces
questions là que nous devons continuer à
aborder avec nos partenaires africains
par ailleurs on va vous allez le faire
pierre vie non continuer à aborder
toutes ces questions diplomatiques
sensibles merci d'avoir été en notre
compagnie merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis pour l'entretien de france 24
[Musique]